Easter eggs endings explained and season
2 predictions these will all be yours as
I heavy spoilers discuss all things one
piece I'm super excited to talk about
the show and throughout this video we're
going to be going through it
all one piece is an incredible series
and I'm happy to say that it breaks the
tradition and now we finally have a
decent live action anime adaptation
first though just a quick word from our
sponsors and then we'll get right into
the video now today's video is sponsored
by bloodline Heroes of liths this is a
dark fantasy hero collector RPG that I
have to say has one of the most unique
game GAA game plays that I've ever seen
with its innovative air system and
breathtaking visuals bloodline takes
RPGs and gcha gamls do an entirely new
level it's absolutely free to play as
well and you can download it by clicking
the link in the description or scanning
the QR code on the screen right now
customize your Champions by marrying any
two Bloodlines of elves demons demigods
or ORS dwarves lyen dragon born vampires
and so on this can create over 4,000
fantasy hybrids and endless
possibilities for your lineups and
matchmaking strategies the hybrids
inherit not only the talents and traits
of their parents but also their unique
appearances passed down from each family
tree infused into one new Bloodlines
with unique abilities and companions
form new genders and they're released
every 2 weeks the game's also designed
with stunning Graphics to provide a top
tier visual experience on mobile phones
and smartpads enjoy collecting fantasy
characters in Full 3D Graphics that's
definitely one of the best mobile games
that I've ever seen all players can
combine uniquely designed hybrid
Champions bloodcraft Legends by earning
points in seasonal Guild Wars raise airs
with Companions sluss and you can switch
genders of companions freely build your
own kingdom and economy with strategic
gameplay and witness the beautiful
scenes and interesting story lines
download the game for free now on both
Android and iOS by clicking the link in
the description or scanning the QR code
you also get a special starter pack
worth $20 by using my link and this
contains one summoning Crystal 100,000
gold and on top of this you get 100
diamonds the first 30 players who leave
their in-game account ID and username in
the first pin comment section below will
receive a legendary female succubus
Champion a luxuriant one of the best
majes to carry you in the game huge
thank you to Bloodline Heroes of liths
for supporting this video and I'm going
to see you in the next part of the
breakdown now over the years we've had
some truly atrocious live action anime
adaptations like Dragon Ball Evolution
Death Note cowboy bbop and so on in a
world where Source material is ignored
and marked in the case of The Witcher or
fans expectations are subverted for no
reason the passion and sheer love for
the iconic Manga and Anime is clear from
the off the show perfectly condenses
major parts of the thousand plus episode
and chapter long anime to bring us what
I think is an incredible start of the
series that I hope goes on for a long
time just like the last verse the
majority of the Manga and Anime is adapt
Ed almost one for one except some
changes to the pacing and all along
becoming The Season's big bad and the
one piece Creator was heavily involved
with the creation of the Netflix show
and whilst other series of movies
adapting beloved comics and games tell
her actors not to read to play The
Source material we know from what the
cast members have said that they were
heavily invested in it Emily Rudd who
plays Nami and aaki who plays Luffy are
big fans of the original Source material
which obviously shows as they bring
these lay characters to life which means
that there someone somewhere cooking but
if you're joining us and have no clue
what one piece is then for the first
part of the video let's let's break the
whole thing down and one piece is a
weekly Manga comic series running from
1997 all the way up to present day it
was serialized in weekly shown and jum
which features many different mangas and
it's also been adapted into an equally
long running anime it's considered one
of the big three of anime and this is
alongside Naro and also bleach now the
story of One Piece follows the exploits
of monkey deffy as he sets out in his
own words to become the king of the
pirate 24 years ago Goldie Roger was
executed at his place of birth log toown
which is where the missing Arc takes
place during the anime and present day
he states that he hid all of the
treasure known as the one piece on an
island at the end of the grand line and
in his final words he challenges people
to go and find
it it led to a golden age of piracy like
when lime wire came out and this is the
opposite to what the world government
want if you're paying close attention to
the scene you can also catch a young
dracool mihawk along with Shanks who
become big characters later on in the
source material go was not actually at
the execution and he was sent by Goldie
Roger to find and protect his son now
the pair had a sort of uneasy Alliance
after their fighting and this is sort of
alluded to when G tells Kobe how they
work with the Pirates the intro to the
show is also the start of the manga and
the intro to every episode is pulling
from the anime season one pretty much
follows the story of the East blue Saga
which is the the main Arc that starts
off the entire Source material we also
have a pre and post time skip split up
as well but all you need to know is
really that season 1 follows the East
blue however the final Arc which is log
toown is missing and I'm guessing that
this is going to pop up at some point in
season 2 now we end as the crew are
about to enter the grand line after they
get the map logtown which is where
Goldie Roger was born and died is the
first stop before the grand line and the
entrance to that is in the reverse
mountain and that was hinted out when
Nami looked at the map in episode 8 and
all the Seas converge to lead up to the
mountain now your first question
probably is what is the grand line well
it's an ocean route that runs the entire
world but it's incredibly dangerous the
world in one piece is actually made up
of the East blue the West Blue the North
Blue and the South Blue Seas with the
red line and Grand line wrapping around
the world entering the grand line is
very perilous as we saw when Don C was
trying to enter and was defeated by
dracul the adaptation has changed things
up and aimed to make things more
traditional like a western tv season for
example we get our big bat of season 1
which is allong who stands in the way of
Luffy getting his map of the grand line
he needs this in order to get to the one
piece and this will help him become the
king of the Pirates allong is sha to be
above buggy and we discover that he's
controlling a fearsome group of pirates
allong is one of the fishmen who were
enslaved by humanity and though they're
now free there's still a lot of
prejudice towards them now their species
home is Fishman Island but it's
segregated with the poor noen fishmen
like all on shunted off it it's here
that all's hatred fested and using their
strength and incredible abilities they
decided to mount up and take over most
of the villages they forced the citizens
to give them tribute which has made them
extremely rich and all's invulnerability
has made him almost Invincible now it
appears that he wants the grand line map
from Ma's hand and this will give him
the location of every Naval base from
arong Park to the Goa Kingdom him having
the map would make him supremely
powerful and it would give him the
ability to take over Society now this
change of him being the big bad of the
whole season and the East blue live
action really cements Luffy and the Cru
win over him as a big big deal as
mentioned the whole of the Season
setting up the crew getting together and
we aren bog down too much in Exposition
as the blending of the flashbacks works
now it's during some of these that we
learn of Luffy's backstory and how he
got the powers from the gum gum devil
fruit these fruits are scattered around
the world and users are able to gain
power unique to that fruit however it
doesn't allow them to swim which I
always found to be a bit of a weird
caveat as it doesn't seem to hinder many
except for Luffy now an important thing
to bear in mind is that if a devil fruit
user is killed their ability appears in
a devil fruit in a random part of the
world which allows the power to be
passed on there are also artificial
devil fruits made using a scientist
named vega Punk's research which will be
a major storyline probably popping up in
the far future now Luffy of course is
given stretchy powers and in my opinion
they look really good and I kind of hope
Kevin is watching this somewhere and
taking down notes now as mentioned
Luffy's life goals to become king of the
Pirates and on his travels he meets a
character called Zoro we meet him on
sixis island along with Mr 7even and can
also see the legend of the Sacred
burning Beast of Baltimore this is a
deep cut reference to frankley who
appears around the time of water 7 where
he appeared like a flaming Beast now
this Mr 7 is another amazingly deep cut
as he's known as Mr 7 previous as he was
previously mentioned by Zoro during The
arabas Rock he was shown in the crew
drawing during the the SPs chapter which
is basically a Q&A section in the
collected volumes now we will discuss
barog Works a bit later in the video as
we discuss the predictions for season 2
and get a little bit spoilery later in
the show we also learn more of zaro's
backstory which going off the anime is
actually my favorite backstory of all
the crew now his rival is the daughter
of AD Dojo leader but she's much more
fleshed out in the original anime we
learned how her father said she cannot
be the strongest as she's a girl and
while Zoro isn't as skillful he will
eventually become much stronger
naturally over time and the pair gained
respect after fighting 2,000 times but
sadly she would trip on the stairs and
he never got the chance to be what he
considered to be the best swordsman now
alongside him on the crew is Nami who's
desperate to make a map of the entire
world we learned throughout the course
of her specific episodes that she was
adopted by a former Marine and has
adopted a sister in nojo Nami was
originally from the yokyok kingdom where
her adopted mother found her and they
ended up going to Coco vill
in the past darlong and his crew arrived
and ordered the place to give them
protection money and over time this
became runess nami's mother was killed
trying to protect her when the table
setting gave away that there were more
people who lived there Nami event she
became an employee of allong and was
hated by his sister and the rest of Coco
Village however she actually had an
agreement to buy the freedom of her
Village and that was actually what she
was working away on now when we join her
in the show she's working to Simply
steal the map at the Grand line and get
enough berries to help by her freedom
however she's played by allong and the
Marine Captain who both work together to
get the millions of berri she's stashed
now Luffy meets both Zoro and Nami at
Shell's town which largely goes down the
same way in the source material complete
with right balls we see as Luffy works
with nami to get the map which she of
course secretly WS so she can help out
all along now things do differ slightly
from the monger and Anime here but I did
like what the show included in Shell
town as Luffy arrives we see there's a
number of wanted posters hanging up
which in the lineup includes C dish
Cavendish is probably my favorite Easter
egg in the show and he appears during an
arc later on that's very well loved
making him an iconic pirate anyway axan
defeated and we close out the entry with
Kobe following his dreams to become a
Marine thematically the series is all
about following your dreams and we see
this as echoed in several characters
throughout Luffy of course wants to
become the king of the Pirates Zoro
wants to be the world's greatest
swordsman and Sanji wants to get
ingredients from the old blue I love how
there's also this idea that the the
generation are happy to help out the
younger ones and this is reflected in
Grandpa mihawk and Chef Seth even at the
end with Luffy's grandfather we see as
he asks the Marines what they follow as
they of course follow orders whilst the
crew follow their dreams even says he
gave Luffy every opportunity to follow
his path and this this idea laay
throughout the show they're very
supportive CU they believe children are
our future and for them to get where
they are they also had to have someone
who helped support them several
characters refuse to step in the way of
the others following theirs and it's a
very inspirational direction to take the
entire series Kobe of course goes after
join the Marines and we watches the crew
make their escape which leads them into
the path of buggy buggy himself has a
major pass working with Shanks on Goldie
Roger ship and he's played by The
Splendid Jeff Ward who played Deacon
Agents of Shield the CGI on the devil
fruit and the chop chop fruit looks
fantastic and Buggies as equally
hilarious as he is terrifying he's one
of the big teasers at the end of the
sees in and he starts off here desperate
for the ground line map it's a close
fight as Luffy is trapped in a water
tank to get the map back as he can't
swim due to the devil fruit pows and the
fight is superb but it's heavily
shortened with the lon tamer in search
not being as involved it's at this point
go finally decides to go after lupy
through using Kobe who's now proper
Cadet the go was actually not as
involved in the anime at this point and
it wasn't revealed until the water 7 Arc
that he was actually Luffy's grandfather
he's introduced much much earlier which
I feel works way better and the
showrunners of course have the 2020
hindsight to bring in elements like this
earlier AARP is simply using his great
resources as a vice admiral to chase
down his increasingly powerful grandson
this is to make sure that he's dedicated
to following his dreams as he is of
course going to be in order to achieve
how Grand they are now through the
scenes with GARP helmo and kobby we
learn the Marines in world government
use the Warlords of the sea to do their
bidding these are Great and Powerful
Pirates which do the jobs that the
government can't really get involved in
ESOP is the next person to join the crew
how we meet him in syrup Village he's
dreamed of a life of adventure like
Luffy and tells Tales to his friend K
he's basically the boy who cried wolf
but rather than screaming about a k9
he's constantly shouting that the
Pirates are coming now much is missing
from his series debut as he had some
kids that followed him round and acted
like his sort of crew but they never
really left their own piece of the world
he does keep his abilities though with
his Keen Marksmanship and later in the
show even uses the exploding star on the
villain cheu the pair work really well
of each other with both wanting to
become the leader and it gets to a point
where they even make their own Flags
this is also where we get to see the
first major ship the crew get which we
learn is called the going Mary later on
they get one called the Thousand Sunny
but that happens much later during the
war 7 Arc usop with his tall tals tries
to get them a deal on the ship named
after its creator who's killed by curo
however this Butler is actually indeed
KIRO and we see that he's part of the
black cat gang he was actually teased
early on as the Black Cat Pirates were
said to be taken out by ax hand and his
portrait was in the safe with the ground
line map now we learned that he's faked
his death and managed to take control of
Kaaya to gain her immense wealth eso's
backstory is largely rush through but it
exists to Simply show his growth from a
boy who idolizes Pirates and pretends
they're coming to someone who has to
take on Pirates himself and become a
powerful person he ends up having a kiss
with k and they certainly seem to make
it more explicit here with there being a
clear romantic Spar now she does appear
over the course of the story and I'm
guessing that she'll be back to keep up
with the events of the crew as we see
Uso becomes immensely attached to the
going Mary and it is sort of an
extension of her or at least he sees it
that way the crew have yet one more
member to get as they need a cook for
the travel across the grand Line This is
more explicitly stated in the anime and
here they head out to baratai it's here
they meet sji who to me felt you know I
did like him but he was just a bit off
from the anime in that he completely
simps for women all the time like it's
really over the top and it leads to some
really hilarious moments he does hit on
NAMI who he's obsess with in the anime
and manga and maybe they just wanted to
tone that back because of it's like 2023
sensibilities which is fair enough now
San here he he's more of a London WI boy
lad with a passion for cooking and I
couldn't help it yeah but he reminded me
of will polter's character in the Fair
season 2 Sanji was a helper in the
kitchen on a ship before it was raided
by zeff and his cooked Pirates and the
pair ended up Shipwrecked on an island
for a very long time Z lied about having
rations as he wanted the kid to survive
and in the end he ate his own leg before
the pair were rescued sanji's aim in
life is to find the old blue a place of
Bountiful ingredients and fish and seen
by others we yet to see it in the source
material but you know with a show
slightly altering things and we might
get some teasers towards it now really
cool detail is he actually just uses his
feet to fight and this is something
known as the black leg style which was
created by zeff now things change up
heavily at these locations as allong
appears much much earlier just like the
anime Luffy ends up not having enough
money to pay for his food and he has to
work off the de by working in the
kitchen found it kind of funny how the
rest of the crew just got drinks after
this while he had to stand and clean the
plates for a inflation yeah it's really
got these restaurant prices going up eh
pre preheat the oven in this
economy here we're also properly
introduced to me Haw and see him going
Toe to Toe with Zoro which leads to Zoro
losing badly the actually know it was
very very well done and makes the
lightsaber fights in the SOA look like
the Star Wars kid as the three sword
Style translated really well to live
action we also learned during this that
Buggy's had his ear and Luffy's had all
his time which looking back was pretty
ingenious now it's at this point that
you know zoro's injured the whole thing
with buggy and we also learn that Nami
is actually working alongside arong in
the end Z finally gives his Blessing to
Sanji to go off and join the crew urging
him to go and live his life and not stay
with a bunch of outcasts it all comes to
a head in the final episode as the crew
arrived to save Nami from allong here
nami's tricked by allong and isumi and
we get a moment where Luffy emotionally
gets her to not give up Luffy ends up
defeating allong in the final fight
which looks stunning again and I was
genuinely surprised at how good the CGI
was right through the Entre season G and
Luffy then have their Showdown which
actually happened much later in the
anime Luffy's laugh is just like Goldie
Rogers and it makes SC realize how
serious that he
is now well go has been training Luffy
his whole life he knows he won't change
and become a Marine he says that he
wanted to make sure that Luffy knew who
he was because GB actually knows his
entire lineage we'll talk about that
more in this spoiler set section but
when you when you learn about his
history you know he won't become a
Marine and that that he was always
destined to become a great pirate now we
get Nami saying goodbye to the home she
only just returned to and see a pin
wheel left at her adopted mother's grave
made out of Mike and peels she gets her
own Mike and Grove on the ship like the
anime and in the source material of pin
wheel was actually something genzo wore
in his hat this was so that he could
cheer up a younger Nami and I really
appreciated how they brought across this
imagery you also see her change her
tatto to pin wheel just like the anime
and this shows where her allegiances
really lie now with all long defeated
the crew are off to the Grand line and
we see his Monkey D now has his first
bounty on his head this happened during
log toown in the anime and it might have
you wondering what's next for season 2
well as mentioned we were missing the
logtown pot of the East blue Saga and
this is located in the pole star Islands
which can be seen in the credits images
the stud of The Saga does feature in the
show with mihawk delivering the Bounty
post to to Shanks and The Crew looking
looking over it the tease of the man
looking over Luffy's bounty is a man
named smoker and he gives g a run for
his money in being a badass now the crew
head to the place where Goldie Rogers
was killed at the stud of the series and
this is to get supplies to then enter
the ground line I mean Zoro needs some
swords and it's here that they come face
to face with smoker he's a vice admiral
of the Marines and commander of the G5
base and he tries to take out the crew
with his second in command this is
tashigi with a G5 being shown on the G
ship's mast and we supp to see buggy and
Alva forming an alliance at the end and
they're also some of the antagonists
that the crew encounter at logtown Alva
at this point becomes dramatically
different having eaten the sub subomi
devil fruit that makes us slippery and
Slimmer we also learned just what our
boy go meant when he said that he always
knew what Luffy is as that kind of
actually has a a little bit of a double
meaning now we will be spoiling what
that is for the next part of the video
so if you don't want that Ru cuz let's
be honest if you're this far into the
video You're invested in the show then
check out now and thank you for checking
us out the thumbs up as always is much
appreciated and make sure you subscribe
to join one piece of our crew out the
way heavy spoilers ahead and yeah let's
get into what GARP really meant now
Luffy's father and garp's son is Monkey
D Dragon a freedom fighter desperate to
overthrow the world government he saw
them as corrupt horrible and shady as
hell and yet let's be honest that's kind
of the case too now the first rulers
founded the world government 800 years
ago as an alliance to combat the great
Kingdom this coincides with 100 years
before that known as the void Century
where all history was wiped out before
the world as we know it was formed
talking and researching about that
century is deadly and this is slowly
unraveled by niik Robin a major
character yet to appear in the show but
she becomes just as integral as any of
the member of the straw hat crew about
log toown is just one Arc as we Blitz
through the arcs this season and the
next Arc is the sweeping epic arabasta
the first Arc of this was teased as Nami
looks at the map and she's confused at a
re that goes up into the mountain that's
exactly what she says as it forms the
entrance to the Grand line in the
opening Ark of arabasta the reverse
Mountain Arc which uh make that make
sense now the villain of The Saga auo's
Works who were teased with zaro meeting
one of them and garp's right-and man
mentioning them a few times there are
crime syndicate set up by one of the
Warlords of the sea crocodile to take
over the kingdom of arabasta and gain an
ancient weapon known as the pluton the
Warlords are Allied to the world
government which is what GARP and hel
Meo hin when they said the world is
complicated now the engine weapons are a
long running mystery and due to their
power used as an excuse by the world
government to forbid researching the
void Century I expect the first episode
of season 2 will be log town as we then
meet the princess of arabasta who at
first works for Baro works that'll then
tell the whole arabas rock with
crocodile working as the big bad for
That season and we'll uncover his secret
plans to rule arabasta even the final
Arc of The arabas Saga where the crew
tried to prevent a runer war that could
be its own season in a way but I do kind
of feel like they'll condense it into
just one overarching season and that's
all of about onepiece ending explained
in season two predictions the show is a
true love letter of the anime and to me
it's going to become the blueprint for
liveaction anime adaptations this is
what you get when you respect the source
material and have the original creators
involved to work on the show as well I
think the season really sung and you
know it's one of those things where you
you binge through it and when it ends
just feel really really sad it's like
you know when um kit Harrington
described reading a good book and
compared that to Game of Thrones well
it's not like Game of Thrones it's not
like that finale cuz that left me
disappointed but this just left me
feeling sad that we're going to have to
wait so long to see these characters
again I think they absolutely nailed it
you know this was a dream come true and
it's so amazing seeing this brought to
live action I did think when it started
off that they were kind of missing the
mark a bit um but you know by the end of
the first episode I was completely on
board and if I have any criticisms yeah
it would be those that minor thing where
it just took me time to adjust I think
anytime when you're doing an anime so
closely you know it might seem a bit
jarring because they're obviously not
pushing for full realism but once you
get on board with it I think everyone's
going to love it this is truly one of my
favorite shows on Netflix ever and yeah
I'm so glad that they delivered to the
level that they should have this just
goes to show exactly why Netflix is
still the king of the streamers and when
they're knocking out things like this
it's really hard to fault them I know
they've had a lot of issues in the past
especially those live action adaptations
but watching it here it's very difficult
to fault it I have been saying for a
while that once the comic book movie
genre dies out that the the industry is
going to shift towards video games but
seeing how much the nailed it here I
think that might not be the case I could
easily see Hollywood going into
liveaction animes just based off how
good this is alone and yeah what a way
to capture the look and feel of the
source material obviously I'm sure you
can tell I loved it but if you have a
different opinion or if you agree then
let me know Below in the comments
section please drop a like and if you
want to support the channel as a member
of the spoiler Society then please click
the join button you get early access to
videos like this every week and we've
got lots of things coming from the world
of Monkey D Luffy if you want to get
some heavy spoilers merch we've also
just launched an aoka t-shirt that will
be linked right below the video and
we've also got things like our Theory
time shirt heavy spoiler shirt and a lot
more we drop new designs on there all
the time so definitely keep an eye out
for them and yeah huge thank you
everyone that picks one up now if you
want something else to watch we've got a
breakdown of a soer on screen right now
going over all the things in the latest
episode we will be back to talk about
some of the Easter eggs in this series
and make sure you just make sure you
keep an eye out for all the content
we've got coming your way huge thank you
for sing through the video in the end
I've been Paul you've been the best and
I'll see you next time take care
peace